les 2500 cadres en recherche d'emploi du
Sud Evelin ont désormais une agence à
leur écoute une antenne Pôle Emploi
dédiée à ce marché à ouvert ses portes à
Guill encour un véritable besoin 70 %
des postes recherchés sur le secteur ont
un niveau supérieur au bac le marché de
l'emploi des CADES est un marché assez
spécifique qui est à la fois très
technique sur lequel on a besoin d'une
expertise pointue pour travailler avec
les les demandes en emploi cadre mais
aussi avec les entreprises et c'est
aussi un marché qui est relativement
caché la plupart des recrutements des
CADES s'effectuent par cooptation réseau
ou candidature spontanée mais certains
postes ne trouvent pas preneur et
souvent les entreprises ignorent que pô
emploi peut leur trouver des candidats
cette nouvelle agence permettra de
renforcer cette intervention auprès des
entreprises tout en multipliant les
opportunités pour les cadres premier
objectif c'est de venir en aide à ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin certains ont
un parcours atypique dans l'emploi et
non'ont jamais eu besoin de rechercher
un emploi se retrouve en position de
Senior de recherche d'emploi donc là en
fait on va
adapter notre nos outils à leurs besoins
les 21 agents de guillancour mettent en
place des ateliers CV y compris en
anglais mais aussi des ateliers vidéo
pour apprendre à se vendre et à
convaincre lors d'un entretien d'autres
ateliers plus spécifiques d'une durée de
6 mois accompagnent les seniors de plus
de 50 ans afin de pénétrer le marché de
l'emploi caché il y a une majorité de
seniors qui sont cadre et qui sont
inscrits dans les agences d'où la
nécessité de cette création pouvoir
faire une affectation et un ciblage des
besoins sur le secteur du Sud Eveline
que gère l'agence plus de 35 % des
cadres en recherche d'emploi sont des
seniors hautement qualifiés cette
nouvelle antenne vient renforcer celle
de Saint-Germain en lait également
réservée à l'emploi des cadres du
département